(gentle upbeat music)
- Hi, this is Lindsay Rose
Medoff from Suay Sew Shop,
and here are three ways to
fight fashion waste at home.
Number one, loving your
clothes make them last.
We're always taught
to not have a sentimental
attachment to clothing,
but we need to be more attached
to the things that we buy
'cause those items took natural resources
and labor to create.
The longer you hold onto things,
the less of an impact it's
gonna have on the environment.
Number two, mending matters.
Every time you patch your clothes
instead of throwing them in the trash,
that's gonna extend the life of them
and reduce the impact on the planet.
Number three is to share
your sustainability story.
Tell your friends and
family what you're up to.
Tell them about choosing used,
recycling, remade, upcycling.
Tell them that there are other options
besides buying brand-new clothing.
The only way that we're gonna
make massive positive change
on the planet, is by doing it together.
(gentle upbeat music continues)